they don't want people to do that when i
was doing mad tv their favorite past
time was to make fun of
jim carrey the great jim carrey what
yeah
that so when i was doing mad tv they're
saying it was like all kids in comedy
all people to make fun of you there is
the benefit of being ancient well
i was doing that i used to make fun well
you like not to your you it wasn't your
idea but they used to have brand new
skits making fun of jim carrey well i
did a skit which was
which was which was it was kind of like
school of acting so i was like showing
you how to use your apps and all that
but i i always respected the [ __ ] out of
him because well
because well he's genius he's undeniable
yeah but he's also coming
in today everybody who was cool in the
comedy world was like
slow dental surgery or jim carrey
and i was like oh yeah but that's with
anything that's a success like
people like you'll hear big names go
kevin hart's name funny i'm like oh
oh really he's not well apparently
somebody thinks he's funny because he's
the
they say with larry's successful selling
club there's a cable guy they're like oh
you should just do that
then go do that and get go do that yeah
yeah yeah yeah if it's that simple go
grab that fifty but
it's it's with it's with anything like
you'll get in music like drake people
make fun of you oh he's so soft like
yeah i don't need my do it i don't need
my guy to be a gangsta rapper like she's
obviously the biggest in the world for a
reason well
it's like who else could pull off ace
ventura right that was
who else could pull i thought that was
[ __ ] genius i was in the i was in the
theater for that
i sat in the theater and watched him and
everybody first of all first of all when
you watch them on the in living color
everybody tuned in for that [ __ ]
oh so everybody everybody tuned in for
that dude doing fire marshall bill and
all that [ __ ] we're all like
where you playing the chick in the
weight room oh my god
at work the next day everybody be like
did you see what he did this week
so what got these [ __ ] to the
dance is genius
and when he did uh ace ventura please
find me please find me a movie or an
actor whoever did something that [ __ ]
insane because
we were dying my mind original school
for a while that's a very original
alec baldwin said we i was doing this
huge movie it was [ __ ] huge
and it was going to be the biggest thing
and along comes this guy nobody's heard
of called
jim carrey doing the craziest [ __ ] and
all of america went
thanks alex
yeah i think about it i'm like i don't
know another actor or actress that could
pull
that character you think of me myself
and irene oh gosh
when he was the other guy yes
kicks to the nose and his nose no
remember when she thinks he's gonna kill
him
yeah yeah he's like and shakes over he's
like what's up [ __ ] fart
he's like so intense she's like i found
rope i found a dildo in the back and
she's like that you're that's for you
yeah it's for you sweetie
he's like all graphics his sons are
black
yeah and no one wants to tell him yeah
yeah and then he's at the barbecue he
goes god damn how long have you tell us
those kids wieners as big as the
sausages
he got some sausages up he's like do you
not know
the beat the water beads off the [ __ ]
back
he's like yeah so oh god the movie's
[ __ ]
hilarious yeah liar liar yeah i'm a good
one too fun we're taking jane
dude he had such a rough oh yeah the
mask
i was
yeah she was so so like it was like i
remember being a young man going
hard it's like the burning bush i
couldn't look at her face i was like
what i was a kid and i was rock hard in
the theater goddamn look at her
smoke you don't get one beautiful show
you don't get more beautiful
i didn't even know she was looked like
that in this oh dude she's
she was she was well you don't get hot
you don't get more beautiful
it just gets different it doesn't get
more beautiful she marry the guy from
good charlotte
she did yep uh one of the twins from she
was so cool benny or whatever she's
so gorgeous i think it's benji yeah
she's astonishing like like what quit
acting she retired
good oh really she did it yeah after a
while
yeah she did that charlie's angels too
she was part of that franchise
on that yeah you didn't like that movie
not up for me but
the women in it though i mean like that
the most lucy lucy lou hello
come on what happened to her she's i saw
her i saw her get her hollywood
oh i saw her amazing hollywood star not
too long ago
well i bet he's funny that guy hit the
water
brendan what what that's such a [ __ ]
insult but so far what did he say it's
such a great
idea because he's funny yeah
there's something going on ugly what
he's like a normal dude
yeah come on normal dude yeah he's in a
big
he's a rock he's a rock star
i do i swear i tell you i like some good
music what would you give his la rating
cameron diaz his husband uh cameron diaz
is la 10 he's a four
you have a full i like i mean he's
probably he's a brayer [ __ ]
talented and cool [ __ ] no that's what
i'm saying i bet he's a great hank
hey by the way they got money you know
by the way though it's also not easy for
cameron diaz necessarily to find a guy
like that that that
is she in trust yeah he has his own
money like yeah he's got he's probably
he's probably a dude yeah i always heard
that like uh
he looks like a dude someone said like
you get money and stuff like you gotta
uh if you're the people are super famous
they gotta find
someone that has as much as them to lose
that makes sense